[Musique]
j'ai monté un nouveau groupe à quelques
jours de la présidentielle
j'ai décidé de monter un groupe en fait
qui chante avec des noms d'hommes
politiques célèbres et pour monter ce
groupe et ben je me suis à soucy toute
l'équipe d'albi qui cartonne trois
millions et demi d'entrées pour le film
animé ce thème fort et on a créé ce
groupe voilà on vous présente l'album
sait de quoi en fait c'est quoi en fait
c'est une pub wallace et c'est la pub du
prochain album qu'on va sortir en mai
dénombre politique dans les chansons
j'aime l'âge de salé comprend le sait
pas elle la politique et la variété
alors qu'on sache c'est l'album et
poetic lovers le 1er 2 et intègre les
hommes politiques dans des tubes
préférés
[Musique]
je ne suis pas
aguëro
son canton
[Musique]
un pur bijou
pas du tout
meetic lovers pas besoin d'attendre deux
premiers tours pour s'acheter leurs 45
[Musique]
dire à tous ces jours le temps où tu
n'as pas de week-end
ce qu acheter un poste d'assistant
parlementaire offerte
[Musique]
jours et je remets le jour
c'est chaud max
[Applaudissements]
formé à nîmes et garçons d'alibi la
foule merci bravo
[Applaudissements]